hey guys what's up this is andrew from
instances.com so in this video i would
like to quickly talk about three stocks
that are looking great where there is a
lot of chatter uh in the past week so i
want to give you my view on dwack dbig
and lucille let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys let's start with dwack so
dwight is a spec that is going to merge
with tmtg
which is the trump social media company
that have already merged actually but
they're going to start their social
media platform on february 21 so let's
first quickly look at the technicals
guys it's very interesting i'm following
the stock of course uh since we saw this
crazy news yes i want you to be there
whenever we have consolidation plus
breakout and i posted this alert on my
discord guess because it was a bookcase
study look at that guys so remember this
kind of configuration because this is
exactly what we're looking for with when
we want to trade breakouts we're looking
for a clear trend line with a few
reactions so here the ping trend line
one two three four five six reactions
only this one is not perfectly clean but
six reactions
and then we have so you can see
very very low volume i don't even see
the volume almost okay here so the
volume were so small then we start to
have
increasing volume uh after the
consolidation and a breakout on even
higher volume all right so i got the
signal uh on my hand around 62 okay this
was for for me the signal that the work
was about to move higher and uh what can
we expect from here so we have this
breakout then we have here one more
resistance at 66 but it got broken then
retested it was a level that we could
use to enter as well and right now i
think we're just gonna keep going higher
let's see what the global market does
but this is a very special stock so i
think that even in the global market
thanks we might see some nice move up
coming here once again we are in the by
the rumor maybe still the news situation
but until february 21st i don't see a
reason why this would drop so i think it
will keep going higher i don't know how
high guys it's very difficult to make
some technical analysis on a stock like
that
i don't know maybe 170 seems too high
guys for february but why not going to
100 120 okay this is possible so let's
see what's gonna happen next month but
once again buy the rumor and maybe sell
the news so i would personally take some
profits before february 21st now next
one bbig guys
dbigs in a nice situation
so this is the daily timeframe you can
see guys for the past year we move down
one two three reactions break out
re-test we go higher one two three four
five six seven eight reactions break out
re-test we go higher one two three four
five reaction so question
look at the volume the volume is really
telling you what uh the sentiment is the
volume is going higher every day move up
move up move up higher volume higher
volume higher volume so this is very
bullish all right this is one
information that is telling me clearly
we have a resistance at 4 420 we have
the 200-day moving average at 408 and we
have this trend line coming here so the
question is are we gonna break it
my view is that probably we're gonna
have a first little rejection because
it's the first time we arrived there and
maybe then break it right away or we
open higher we found resistance at 480
which is the natural level of resistance
as we can see
here here here here lows here on the
highs here the consideration
we retest the breakout level around four
and then we go higher and of course the
bearish case we get rejected and you
know we found maybe a little bit of
support but we go lower that's possible
as well guys i didn't find any news
maybe i didn't look
good enough for news so just tell me in
the comments if there are some news i
missed but
to me this is just a rally because
everybody is suddenly talking about that
so my fears that you guys know that we
were talking a lot about dbig in the
past few months there are a lot of bag
holders guys those guys they're probably
gonna exit the position around this
levels so maybe not all right so
here my view is 50 50. i don't know
what's gonna happen but i know that if
we break four i would try to uh buy on a
retest here but only if we break it for
good for a few days all right so that
it's not a fake out because i don't like
to trade breakouts whenever i don't have
this nice consolidation like i had on
the walk for example so here my once
again and we have a lot of gamma guys
let me show you that
okay
up i'm
completing everything
so we have a lot of game i guess as you
can see around the four five six strikes
on jan maturity as you can see here are
huge we have 40 million shares
coming mostly from the five six strikes
so for 4.5 even four so this means and
it's next week guys this means that
there's gonna be a lot of pressure on
option market makers and that if we go
through this there's gonna be a big
pressure on the upside by these guys
that need to buy when the price goes up
so it's one more reason to think that we
might squeeze yes that's something that
might very well happen but we might also
if all the back holders decide to take
profits the
option gamma is not strong enough to
create a squeeze so it's really gonna
depend on the sentiment and what people
do with their shares all right and i
don't have an answer about that so once
again my plan is to wait to see if we
have a breakout and maybe to enter on
the retest last one guys lucid so once
again a nice situation here so we were
waiting for this breakout for quite some
time this is a nice breakout guys
because we have here look at this trend
right the market is making higher lows
with the momentum making lower lows so
it means we take back energy all right
so this is the sign of a healthy trend
this is one more thing that i will show
you guys in the course that i'm creating
that is gonna be released in two weeks
hopefully guys i'm finished with almost
everything you're gonna see it's gonna
be amazing and i'm explaining everything
in this course and for example one very
important thing is to look for breakouts
in healthy trends this is a healthy
trend because once again you you can see
the momentum had time to uh go lower
when the price action was going higher
which means we reloaded some energy and
we are ready to go higher so then we
have this bullish hidden divergence then
here we have a bullish regular
divergence the market is making lower
lows but the momentum is making higher
lows i think we see it well on the rsi
okay you can see here on the macd it's
not obvious but on the other side the
rsi is making higher lows so this is a
sign of reversal so we have a long term
bullish hidden divergence which which
says the trend is healthy and likely to
continue and we have a bullish regular
divergence on the short term telling us
the correction might be over then we
have the breakout so here same thing i
posted an alert i'm in this trade we
moved quite higher then we got severally
rejected it might be only a pullback so
you can measure the last move up and use
flips to enter so usually after such a
move uh you can use the 50 61.8 percent
they're good to enter so 40 39 all right
i'm going to increase my position here
hopefully it's going to hold maybe it's
not going to hold you you never know
this is trading right but this is a very
nice setup and if it holds and if we are
able to push higher the target is around
17 for the uh coming month or maybe two
months so that's it for me guys i hope
you enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to shore as
you guys